she still got it
and only we can show you what happened
on set of Janet Jackson's new music
video damn baby et was behind the scenes
with the icon her producer and the
director of her sexy new video really
were just after the core Janet with this
we wanted to strip down and just give
you full blast what the fans have been
asking for I think that people have been
waiting to seeing her dance like this in
a video for quite a while what's great
about it is she's so creative and she
doesn't like to get bored so she always
is constantly thinking of new things to
do now this was just before Janet
dropped a bombshell last month delaying
her tour actually has been a sudden
change my husband and I are planning our
family I have to rest up doctor's orders
fans were stunned by the 49 year olds
announcement that she has her
billionaire husband are quote planning a
family please if you can try and
understand that it's important that I do
this now this isn't the first time the
graining winners unbreakable tour has
hit a bump last October she rescheduled
several shows after doctors ordered her
to rest her vocal cords in December
Janet announced she had to have surgery
postponing the second leg of the tour
until spring and there were rumors she
was battling cancer but the singer
quickly shot those down with a video
that said quote the rumors are untrue I
do not have cancer I am recovering Janet
health-wise is doing very well she
appreciated so much the support from the
fans she always wants to make sure that
she's really giving the fans and
everybody their best so sometimes you
have to take a little time
you